Louisiana's Democratic governor says he
will sign a bill banning abortion as
early as the sixth week of pregnancy
without exception for rape or incest
legislators passed the bill yesterday
joining five other states was so-called
heartbeat bills including Missouri that
state is also poised to close its only
abortion facility tomorrow CBS news.com
broke that story CTM national
correspondent that's Jericka Duncan is
outside the Planned Parenthood clinic in
st. Louis with more on this story
Jericka so why is a clinic struggling
then to keep the doors open well here's
what's happening today Gale in a
critical hearing a judge could grant a
restraining order that would essentially
prevent the state health officials from
refusing to renew the license here at
Planned Parenthood which expires
tomorrow now Missouri state health
officials say that this clinic has been
under investigation because of quote
ongoing concerns about potential
deficient practices at the clinic adding
that Planned Parenthood has still not
agreed to full compliance with state
regulations Republican governor mike
carson gave examples of those concerns
yesterday which included records of
alleged failed surgical abortions he did
not however say which violations the
organization has not been able to fix
now on CTM yesterday you may recall of
course Planned Parenthood CEO Lena when
said Missouri State officials are trying
trying to quote weaponize the
inspections process to ban abortion now
if this Planned Parenthood here loses
its license Missouri would become the
first state in the country where there
is no facility for women to have these
abortions that hasn't happened Anthony
since the roe v-- wade decision back in
1973 alright Jericka Duncan Thank You
jurika